le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
alcool cigarettes drogues pour lutter
contre ses addictions
le département a mis en place les points
info santé ces centres d'accueil
dispersés aux quatre coins de l'île
s'adresse à tout type de public
souhaitant bénéficier de conseils sur
les risques sanitaires
parce qu'il n'est jamais facile
d'arrêter sans accompagnement nous avons
rencontré sophie qui nous parle de son
combat pour vaincre la cigarette
[Musique]
mais ça a terminé sa montre
plus concentrés plus patiente c'est
sereinement que sophie s'attaque aux
devoirs de son fils elle a arrêté la
cigarette il ya cinq mois
fumeuse depuis trente ans un bilan
médical récent lui détecte du diabète
pour cette mère de famille c'est le
déclic
donc à la suite de samalut un
rendez-vous avec le cardiologue a dit
mon bain avec sa puce avec la cigarette
ça m'a fait qu'aggraver les choses
par la suite ça cogite dans la tête et
on se dit oui si on veut vivre plus
longtemps c'est le moment je me disais
mais bientôt je pourrai de la
cinquantaine faudra bien que j'arrête
sophie s'adresse alors au service
addictologie de l'hôpital bellepierre
pour se faire accompagner première
visite tu as un rendez vous avec une
affiche à milhac bon kit explique tous
les désagréments de la cigarette
ensuite elle te donne des conseils il ya
un médicament il ya le le patch ya les
pastilles les gommes
on peut réussir tout seul mais se faire
aider l'enfant et pour se faire aider
la dionysienne aurait également pu se
rapprocher du point info santé lecointe
santé bonjour ce service départemental
propose au public une écoute et des
conseils sur toutes les questions de
santé
ça s'adresse à tout public en fait quand
on est tous publics et des familles des
étudiants des personnes âgées des
professionnels de l'éducation nationale
les points info santé font partie des
dispositifs mis en place par le
département pour lutter contre les
fléaux de lille les problèmes de santé
importants la réunion c'est d'abord
l'alcoolisme le tabagisme qu'avec qui
sont de grands fléaux
le tabac tue chaque année 250 personnes
à la réunion
l'alcoolisme nous avons un taux de
mentalité trois fois supérieur au niveau
national et puis tout ce qui est diabète
et les maladies cardiovasculaires ou là
ou rondes détient aussi des records
nationaux
nous nous avons décidé de nous impliquer
fortement dans la prévention des
addictions
fabienne est animatrice de prévention en
plus de ses conseils elle peut proposer
au public de la documentation gratuite
et officiels
on est dans le centre documentaire où
les gens peuvent entrer et prendre de la
documentation en fonction leur problème
ce matin l'animatrice réunit des outils
pour préparer la prochaine journée
d'information là je prépare un événement
c'est la journée sans tabac dont le
thème cette année c'est le tabac et les
maladies cardiovasculaires une journée
qui pourrait intéresser sophie qui de
son côté lutte contre les tentations du
quotidien le plus dur c'est les sorties
entre amis
les soirées très très difficile parce
que dès qu'on a voulu un petit un petit
apéro ça y est on est tenté moi j'ai ma
technique âgées la technique de l'eau
glacée donc quand j'ai envie je prends
un grand verre d'eau glacée pour pas y
penser je me mets au ménage astic
je m'occupe je lis je fais autre chose
des sacrifices contrebalancée par de
belles surprises et redécouvertes déjà
le sommeil le soir vous avez et bi
balogou le goût les odeurs le fait de
monter les escaliers potes en a pas
beaucoup
les moisi souffler mais peut courir
parce que mon travail que les enfants
des samis arrivait plus à le faire
aujourd'hui
sophie se sont épanouis et détermine
vraiment méfié lé mans le déclic est en
toi il faut pas hésiter
on sera jamais
des non fumeurs au sort des ex fumeurs
on sera toujours tenter le fait d'avoir
essayé c'est déjà bien et puis si si on
n'a pas réussi cette fois on va réussi à
l'autre fois prochaines à ce jeu me dit
quand on veut on peut
[Musique]
avec quatre centres d'accueil sur l'île
les points info santé propose diverses
actions dans le cadre de la
sensibilisation et l'éducation à la
santé
des ateliers sont organisés dans leur
structure mais également l'extérieur
dans les écoles ou des maisons de
quartier c'est dispositif s'adresse à la
fois aux particuliers mais également aux
professionnels souhaitant mettre en
place des actions de prévention
pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous rapprocher des points info santé le
plus proche à saint-denis saint-andré
saint pierre et saint paul où vous
rendre sur le site du département ou
www.dhltd.com en 9 7 4 point fr lien
social accompagne les réunionnais pour
la mobilité frais d'une dalle amis j'ai
21 ans je suis supporter apprentissage
ça fait bientôt deux ans et j'ai vu un
de l'île de la réunion dans le centre
saint denis il si chers apprentis
trépied tous les matins quand j'arrive
je peux par les préparations froides
commencer par la salade des frais puis
j'étudie mon patin galettes de pâte à
crêpes pour commencer le service du midi
ballard pour moi même vidic avant les
thèmes bien en bas et maintenant comme
me grâce à ce métier je puis savoir mes
performances nos compétences exemple les
factures d'eau et factions de la maison
et tout ça mais tant les responsables et
autonomes
c'est bien fait pour nous tous les
jeunes ben ça nous apprend vraiment
laverie
comment ça fonctionne si bien
[Musique]
oh